hey guys what's up you're watching D LM
model lifestyle I'm Daniel
and on this video I'm gonna talk about
how I started my modeling career if this
is your first time on my channel
subscribe and hit the bell so you won't
miss the next video
all right so how did I start my modeling
career now I grew up in South Africa but
I was born in the midea my parents moved
to South Africa when I was around three
years old and the earliest memory that I
have that's got anything to do with
modeling was when my sister asked me and
my brother to do some modeling poses to
gave us these kind of posters we call
them we were pointing to Cindy Crawford
and some of the models and it looked
like we were arguing we had to do this
Porter anyway that was the earliest
thing that I remember little did I know
that I would become a male model when I
grew up anyway
as I grew up I was really into sport
I really enjoyed rock viola
and we moved to a new place in Pretoria
and I remember when I came back from
school I passed by this modelling school
and I saw it quite a few times and I
always wondered what did i do there what
what is this all about I had no idea
what modeling is about and this one day
I remember I saw this girl going in
there and she was really beautiful and I
went back home and I asked my mom mom I
want to go and see what's going on in
the modelling school if I should do some
modeling classes or something well
there's only one reason why I wanted to
do it right anyway when I got there they
had these classes or four models and
they taught you some stuff but they had
this competition and they said well we
don't have the classes now but next week
we'll have a competition so why don't
you come along just join the competition
and you'd see if you're interested in
modeling or not so I said yeah okay
that's fine I did a competition I won I
won a few stuff
I was really surprised but then we moved
again away from that area to another
place and I stopped doing modeling and I
just continued doing rugby and when I
finished school I wasn't sure what I
wanted to do yet
[Music]
and I decided to go to England so I went
to England I stayed there for a year and
a half I work for a Scotties in southern
company and I did really really good but
then I heard the news of my brother he
passed away in South Africa so it was a
really hard time for me and my family
and I and I came back to South Africa
and after a while I started to study
psychology and then I saw this modeling
school and I went back to this modeling
school and for the reason because
there's beautiful girls and I was kind
of just like a hobby and then they had a
very big competition I think they called
it the model of the year or something so
I said yeah well I'll do it you know I
can win a few things why not and there
were a few Scouts there at the
competition and there was one guy who's
very adamant and he said Daniel you'll
be able to be a very good model I want
to take you to a model agency in
Johannesburg so I gave in I went with
him to sit down with this model agency
Jonas burger and the guy said I had a
very good look I need to lose a little
bit of white and I was a little bit of
10 kilos over the weight he was very
specific and he said they are not a
modeling school they just the modeling
agency so they will get me modeling jobs
in South Africa
so I had no idea why modeling is about
how much money I can make where I can
travel I had no idea so as I joined the
agency and
my first official fashion shop or in
South Africa Fashion Week and oh man I
was nervous I remember walking down that
runway and my my eyebrows started to
twitch my my lips started to to shaking
ah it's quite nerve-wracking I'm
actually a shy guy I was very very shy
and after the first few shows then it
was normal but um yeah it was quite a
hectic time anyway then there was a
scout there the fashion week from Taiwan
and they said Daniel we'd loved if you
can come to Taiwan and work there for
this agency and so I went back to my
agency in Johannesburg and I said is
this Scout the one we to travel to
Taiwan I didn't even know you can travel
with model and they said Daniel we think
you're not ready you're not experienced
you don't have a good book so we advise
against it and so I sold them but I
really want to go and I think I can I
can work so they said well if you want
to go then we will not be your mother
agency we cannot vacuum and then I said
well that's fine so I went with all the
mother agency and that agency I don't
want to say any names but I went to
Taiwan I looked on the line on websites
like muddled mayhem and other websites
before I travel teams I want to look
table to look up for photographers to do
some sessions with them so I build up my
book pretty quick it wasn't a very good
book but at the least I had some
pictures and then I went to Taiwan
I made a really great success I had a
lot of jobs and it was a really really
good time that I had there was my first
time that I had very instant Asia I made
a lot of good friends as well and I came
back to South Africa and then later I
joined the modelling agency called star
and Janice Burke and I chose them as my
mother agency and I've been with them
since while it's been eight nine years I
think star models merged with boss
models in South Africa so now move boss
models in Johannesburg not Bosma was in
Cape Town but I am with contact in Cape
Town yeah that's another story for
another time but anyway then I did
another South Africa Fashion Week and
then there was this camera crew and they
said anyone would love to put you on a
TV show where we just show your kind of
lifestyle and I said yeah sure so I did
that TV show which was interesting I'll
show you a quick clip here was it can
you come out with a young without that
in some Olivia can you honest but was it
who I thought the current is I do have a
dim focus it was feather or purple was
it me combo control NOC - lottery yellow
dog so meeting Darren
[Music]
Daniel Burruss influence piece of the
umidollar and said Africa martyr Falchi
our diversity reverb on procession of 2l
in a star humble home from South Atlanta
bosses are October it's the whole
package he hide the body he can do
anything to this one week in this shows
you can do magazines you can do
editorial and he's very versatile so
clients love booking Daniel disease are
all rhyme with kind of muddled and they
also like that he who knows how to
perform as a model in front of a camera
[Music]
[Applause]
Stoll's and TV pay more than red but
rampers fun and a lot of explosion the
right people are sitting in the audience
either you can walk in and then my
modeling career just skyrocketed I
started traveling to a lot of places I
could choose from which countries I want
to go to I went to Singapore I went to
China I went to Japan I went to Korea I
went to countries like Germany and Paris
I went and traveled quite a lot and it
was really cool it was really a fun
experience I did it mostly for the
travelling that's what most models do it
and so traveling to all these different
countries who has a really good
experience and still they it's time just
flew by and now I've been doing modeling
for 12 years and I don't know where it's
gonna end up but I am really enjoying
the journey right and we'll see where it
will end up and I just want to thank all
of you guys for supporting me on my
youtube channel and asking the questions
in the comment sections below and if you
have any other questions please go ahead
and ask me more the channel grew really
quick and I'm really surprised by it and
I don't always have the time to answer
to all of you and I think as the channel
grows it's going to become a lot more
difficult but I will try to answer your
questions in the videos like the one I'm
doing right now alright now if you're
new on the channel please subscribe and
I'll see you in the next video thanks
guys
[Music]